best product does not win today the best
known product wins
you think starbucks sells the best
coffee please nasty you need to think of
way bigger than you're thinking get your
money right son
worry about the money need motivation
watch the top 10 would believe nation
what's that believe nation it's evan i
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and join
today's isis from a man who went from
coming out of a drug rehab center at age
25 to becoming a millionaire five years
later to now owning over half a billion
dollars in real estate
he's grant cardone and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success vol 12 also
if you want to know a grant cardone and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days i will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below you have to go
build self-confidence
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one get attention when I started a
Twitter account I had no followers when
I started Facebook counting no followers
I was my first follower when I started
an Instagram account no followers I
didn't know how to post video I didn't
know how to take a selfie I didn't know
how to do any of this but I did have a
commitment to grow in my finances and if
you want to grow your finances attention
is the gateway you want to go to heaven
who wants to go to heaven you got to die
I'm just telling you man you got to die
to go to the heaven and most people
don't want to die they want to go to
heaven but they don't want to die most
people want money but they're not
willing to get the attention they're not
willing to do what it takes to get the
attention including spending money and I
would just tell you this if you want to
change your financial condition the
first thing you need to do is go out and
market in the marketplace so that you
can create a lead and not worry about
whether there's ROI or not it's so
stupid
that people like what's the ROI do
what's the ROI if nobody knows you okay
what's the ROI if I don't know your name
don't know your company don't know what
you do don't know your service don't
know your product don't know where
you're located what is the ROI okay
best product does not win today the best
known product wins
you think Starbucks sells the best
coffee please nasty
[Music]
okay but it's close and I know what I'm
getting when I get there McDonald said
let's sell the best hamburger clothes
and available rule number two think
bigger so that brings me to the second
point you need to think of way bigger
than your thinking I started in the
apartment game twenty-five years ago in
San Diego California my first deal first
deal I ever bought was one unit this
little yellow house that I paid seventy
eight thousand dollars for by the way
all this landscaping that's one of the
things I'm known for him like I'm
putting trees up there because that's
gonna give me some extra rent it didn't
by the way my next door was 38 units
okay it was easier by 38 units than it
was one the only difference was to think
I had to think different got to make a
few more phone calls but the play is
bigger right the reason people the
reason so many real estate people are
like marginal people no offense raise
your hand if your marginal they left on
raise your hand if you liar
look man look I'm more chill too
compared to my potential fact that
there's people in this room that don't
know me I've written seven books
thirteen best-selling business programs
I have I'm probably the top one or two
maybe three social media people in the
world seven million people on Facebook
but 7 million people on Facebook is
nothing compared to 7 billion people in
the world so think big man rule number 3
solve problems problems are
opportunities the bigger the problems if
you could look for the giant problems on
this planet and quit complaining about
them right and quit blaming somebody
about it and say man what if I took
responsibility for that problem
because there is money in solving
problems you solve a problem you'll end
up with money and the bigger the problem
you solve the bigger the problem you
solve the more money you end up with
rule number 4 study success 40 years of
my life I was being held back by what I
do
that are hooking up with whoever they
want when they want that are spending
millions and millions and millions of
dollars of connections and speed and
access
what are they doing man
they're doing something different than
you and I will talk to do school systems
don't teach you this your mama didn't
she didn't
your family doesn't know this right so
you got to go outside your circle of
influence
big jet on the tarmac
all the way up the food chain
you can do the same thing
study hard enough the right people
not those guys those are the pilots
see they worked for 150 grand a year
figured they're they're cutting a big
fat hog in the ass oh I make 175 dozen
but they stop learning what the owner
knows
they studied and study paid the price
for the information and then pay for the
price of access to the people and learn
from rule number five worried about the
money if I could go back to my 20 year
old self what I would tell my 20 year
old self is one thing get your money
right son
worry about the money and I know a lot
of people think that this is not the
thing people should be focused on
however on this planet if you don't get
your money right you're gonna be worried
all the debt all the time you can't take
care of your parents you can't take care
of yourself you can't take care of your
rent you can't live in a nice place you
can't take care of your car get your
money right okay what should you be
spending your money on why do wealthy
people use money not spend money why do
wealthy people buy businesses they don't
buy homes why to wealthy people use debt
to grow their business they don't use
debt to consume products and services
why do wealthy people not invest in 401
K since EPS and retirement accounts they
don't even worry about that they worry
about getting their money so freakin
right if they can go wherever they want
day or night
rule number six change your target just
saying hey man if you got a million
dollars you're basically just a freakin
deadbeat and that your daddy didn't tell
you that if you didn't have any more
income then you were held or you you're
27 years old I'm gonna do this at 47
i'ma do it at it's 65 27 you don't have
any more income how long would that
money laughs at $4,000 a month you got
25 years where can you live on $4,000 a
month you'd have the level of $4,000 a
month for 25 years you will be 52 years
old my friend and dad broke number one
thing you got to do is this you got to
change the target and you need to look
at the target daily the target you have
the wrong target right now if you're
struggling you have
the wrong target when you change the
target everything changes now and I
started with zero just so you guys know
I didn't have anything okay so look it's
simple target what's your new target
breathe yeah freedom but but but let's
put my number one your first target
should be ten million dollars and
nothing short of that number one the
target number two you need to get your
income to a place this is a fascinating
concept right here okay if you can do
this I guarantee you'll be rich you need
to get your income not to what pays your
bills but to where you can say 40% of
your gross income is saved
all right so now now when you do this
math you're like good how much money do
I actually need let's kick this up to 20
grand at 20 grand what happens you're
saving 8 storage you're paying 8 and now
you can live on 4c now this is the right
way to do a budget you make 30,000 the
12 is going to storage the twelves going
to the hour and the S and at least you a
6 so now you can start seeing that you
got to be somewhere north of 300 grand a
year this is what they don't teach you
at Harvard you got to be somewhere north
of 360 a year before you even have money
to live on unless you're just you know
you're a trek you're just the
irresponsible human being that that's
you know not putting storing money away
for the future ok now you're saving 12
grand a month that's 144 thousand
dollars in one year in 10 years that's
1.4 million dollars in 10 years you're a
millionaire stored you guys need to be
heavily money motivated from a survival
standpoint okay number three thing
you're gonna do you're gonna go broke
right here and invest the storage
storage has to get invested the Golden
Goose is only good if she lays eggs
otherwise you can kill her either for
chicken knee takes bait money needs to
make babies right so your goal right
here is ten best to invest the storage
money and continue to do that until this
money over here
the passive money is equal to your
income right so what would I do I'd go
out I'm gonna make 30 grand I'm gonna
store 12 on the paid to IRS on the live
on 6 Warren Buffett says don't lose
money number one number two don't lose
money I would tell you number three
don't lose money and that's the reality
of the situation that's what Peter Thiel
was saying a single-digit millionaire
cannot even provide themselves with
their own personal defense in America
okay
Hulk Hogan all that money Hulk Hogan
made he blew it all he blew it off
probably buying hair pieces okay he blew
it all he blew it all ended up with a
little money thought he was this oh man
I got a little money until he had that
frickin lawsuit and then he can't even
defend himself so it happens to a lot of
people how many of units a family member
lost her job okay how many have a family
member where the kid got a drug
addiction he had to go to rehab for 30
days and it cost 40 grand good bad
happens how many know somebody got
cancer okay
how many know somebody to car accident
cost three or four hundred Rand Abbott's
okay problem is not the staff as happens
if people are ready for who got a cue
belief this happened to me oh really
god damn you been around long enough
right how many of you can't swim I'm
just saying you might want to get us
women less it's a wet planet rule number
seven find your greatness I love
baseball but but but you don't have to
love baseball one touch to be inspired
by greatness watch this but yes but yes
[Music]
greatness man that's greatness I got
that guy you know when you when I watch
that I'm like I wonder how many times
she's run jumped taken flight which I
mean thousands and thousands and
thousands of times to get to have that
moment right there so by the way that's
that's an everybody here okay so if you
ever see a great ballplayer whether it's
football or hockey or ballet or dancing
and you're inspired it's because it's
hitting that part of you that's like you
have that in you rule number eight
change your thinking yeah you got it you
got it you got yeah everywhere you go
you need you need to confront every time
you hit up against oh the the rooms 249
the the Mills 25 bucks
Starbucks is six dollars the airline
flight costs six under every time you
like oh okay
you need to understand that you're being
reminded you don't have enough
it has nothing to do with the price but
watch how much people disassociate
American Airlines has charged it too
much than that ticket that has nothing
to do with it you know you don't make
enough money okay so I had a guy I was
in Oakland California I was flying back
and I said hey anybody want to fly home
with me the guy's like I want to fly
home with you I'll do it I said good
I'll be $48,000 for fuel oh oh I don't
want to do it no you can't do it because
you don't have the money
fuel is not the problem he didn't he
done make enough money so just start
flipping things so like now when I see
Wagyu remember that Wagyu we ate in
Vegas it looked like a hundred and
fifteen dollars first strip that big
never do it again by the way but the
fact that I complained about it only
means I don't make enough money and if
the Wagyu is too much money
if the 115 for a little strip of Wagyu
is too much money what does that say
about what I'm selling my products for
not charging them up can't get enough I
have this idea so it's really true to me
it's really we go to Paris man and we go
to this Chanel store and there's people
in line in line out the front door at
the Chanel store like all my kind great
experience for me how much money's on
this planet go to Monaco see the yachts
two hundred million two forty three
hundred million dollars three hundred
millions they cost thirty million a year
to take care of great experience
flying private been a great experience
for me okay guy has five jets not not
he's not complaining about a first-class
CD anymore in the peanuts
he's got five jets different level man
I'll send you start thinking different
start asking different start working
deals different rule number nine do more
I was 50 52 years old and I had a
problem I was depressed I wasn't
satisfied
I was hungry but didn't know what to do
I had businesses I had money I had a
whole bunch of stuff but I'm like - what
am i doing now
I'm bickering with Elena we had our kids
we had the first two kids and we're like
okay we got a kids I'm being a parent
now okay I'm being a married guy right
I'm being a businessman and I'm unhappy
and then I start asking people what's
wrong man what's wrong what's wrong with
me man something wrong with me something
wrong with me oh yeah and as soon as you
say something wrong with me it
everybody's got an opinion oh yeah man
and you got a disease man you got a
problem you got issues man you work too
much you're a work attic you you you you
you you're insecure your daddy died your
daddy died and left a hole in you left a
hole in me I can't go on a vacation I
want to do something man doing less has
never solved my problems doing less
moderation has never solved a problem
for me the problem that I've had in my
life okay was not my marriage there's
not okay I'm not a bad parent you should
be up here
you should be dropping out of the
ceiling you should be helping more
people and rule number 10 the last one
we for a very special bonus clip is have
fun before you had that live chat you're
having second thoughts about the wake
surfing what changed your mind
I don't know I mean I always I'm always
up for an adventure you know it's just
people get grouped into their comfort
zones yeah yeah you can make about busy
I'm this and that but like the reality
is
you know people just how would you say
this is out of your comfort zone any if
I'm not working to deal
I'm Adam I come from give you nice don't
pull myself up
[Music]
[Applause]
you
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from grant on how to get out of the fear
that I think you're gonna really enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions time to move
from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go
question number one what does a 10x life
look like for you number two what needs
to change in your habits to get there
and number three what do you need to
eliminate from your life to get there
if you guys look around man it would
appear to me that 99% of the people that
you run into today are having some kind
of financial problem
Oh 76% of Americans live paycheck to
paycheck I know people that don't live
paycheck to paycheck don't worry about
money every second of every day when my
dad died I didn't know anything about
the 1% but I knew I wanted to get in
that Club I'm like I have to get above
whatever this middle-class thing is
because there's no safety here it's
constant fear I've only wanted money for
one reason to be out of fear so I could
help out so I could give to charity so I
could help my brother so I didn't have
to worry about how much the fuel costs
or do I run an ad budget or not man you
guys got to get out of the fear man
that's the whole purpose okay the fear
by the way is not a conspiracy that's
real everybody like Oh fear ain't real
yeah well uh huh it's easy for you to
say you ain't got any this second okay
because it ain't scary to write a damn
quote or to post something on Instagram
that's scary what's scary is going to
take a loan for sixty million dollars
see if you ain't got a little bit of
scare okay say you know to a customer
hey man you're wrong okay my set my
daughter told me that day
customers robberies right papa no
they're not no they're not and most
people don't even know how to tell a
customer they're all okay best customers
I have I told no that's not true that's
not right you're wrong and I'll show you
why
[Music]
yeah the most important work ever if you
had to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you Apple
that would be connect a little beacon
[Music]
if you want more grant cardone check out
the top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there so you don't get
attention today you have absolutely zero
chance of being successful money follows
attention